[Música]
las tropas rusas avanzan rápidamente
hacia el donbass y nuestros enviados
especiales estuvieron con los hombres
que defienden los pueblos que todavía se
encuentran bajo control ucraniano y que
son atacados permanentemente por rusia
manifestantes surcoreanos salieron a las
calles de seúl para rechazar la visita
de joe bailén ante el temor por el
fortalecimiento de los vínculos
militares entre los países de un
eventual aumento de la inseguridad en la
península y continúa la crisis
migratoria en la frontera sur de eeuu la
norma tituló 42 que el año pasado se
utilizó para expulsar a más de un millón
de personas sigue siendo aplicada para
los solicitantes de asilo
hola bienvenidos una vez más a las
noticias de france 24 en español soy
santiago ariztía y comenzamos con
información desde ucrania las tropas
rusas han avanzado rápidamente en los
últimos días en la región más este del
donbass todavía bajo control ucraniano
nuestros enviados especiales catalina
gómez ángel y mikel konaté estuvieron
con los hombres que defienden los tres
pueblos que todavía tiene en control
ucrania al este de severodonezk y que
son atacados permanentemente por rusia
el comandante ya no tiene a su cargo una
las posiciones de las fuerzas ucranianas
al este de la ciudad de severodonezk
el último ataque fue hace unas horas
atacaron la posición vecina los atacaron
con bombas racimo fósforo con todo lo
que quisieron
las tropas rusas están en el bosque a
menos de un kilómetro
está bien
es así
la batalla por severodonezk y la
provincia a los hanks es la más intensa
que se libra actualmente en ucrania esta
es una de las tres poblaciones al oeste
de cebrones que todavía permanecen en
control de los ucranianos para ellos son
fundamentales porque de llegar las a
perder la ciudad quedaría prácticamente
encerrada las tropas rusas atacan sin
cesar estas poblaciones cientos de
integrantes del ejército de moscú que
han sido expulsados en las últimas
semanas de otras regiones de ucrania
pelean en este frente ahora por nuestros
de subir ahora todas las fuerzas rusas
se están trasladando a este territorio
es muy difícil es muy complicado
utilizan tanques pero especialmente la
artillería como estrategia para doblegar
a la defensa ucraniana como resultado
van dejando poblaciones destruidas y
muchas veces arrasadas
el comandante andreas y tiene a su cargo
la defensa de otra posición hay un gran
riesgo al estar en este pueblo han
atacado en frente de la casa atacaron la
casa de los vecinos están tratando de
destruir todo por completo ellos ven un
asentamiento y su objetivo es destruirlo
aquí todos tienen que permanecer bajo
techo los drones rusos sobrevuelan
haciendo trazados sobre el terreno
este es el cuarto de operaciones su
estrategia disuadir al enemigo y nos
dará la oportunidad de atacar
para esto se apoyan en las nuevas armas
enviadas por países occidentales como
esta lanzadera
[Música]
en los bosques donde los tanques y el
equipo pesado del enemigo no puede pasar
tenemos menos pero en otros terrenos
abiertos con mayor amenaza hay más y
todos los hombres saben ahora cómo
usarlos
[Música]
reconocen que la llegada de este
armamento ha elevado la moral
aún así saben que esta es una de las
batallas más difíciles
rusia tiene superioridad aérea y ahora
enfoca toda su fuerza en tomar el
control de severodonezk
y vamos con más noticias las altas
temperaturas afectaron a españa durante
esta semana y la agencia meteorológica
nacional emitió advertencias de
temperaturas extraordinarias en días de
regiones del país y la población se está
adaptando como pueden melissa chávez
rincón con los detalles
calor intenso en españa en algunos
lugares del país ha superado los 40
grados centígrados los trabajadores en
las calles de madrid tratan de continuar
con sus labores a pesar de las altas
temperaturas
fatales
esto era agobiante
vamos a ver a ver qué tal durante este
mes de mayo la temperatura promedio de
algunas ciudades fue entre 7 y 16 grados
centígrados más altas que el promedio
habitual para esta época del año mayo
siempre ha sido o fresquito más
fresquito pero este le he visto que ha
ido de tirón al verano pero bueno hay
que seguir adelante
los madrileños tratan de resguardarse
del calor bajo sombra y tomando bebidas
frías la agencia estatal de metereología
para el tiempo y el clima les alertaba
de las altas temperaturas para la semana
del 16 al 22 de mayo con riesgos altos
de incendios en 10 regiones del país
temperaturas muy elevadas para la época
del año en la mayor parte del país para
los próximos días excepto en canarias se
superarán los 35 grados en muchas zonas
y más puntualmente 40 grados en
localidades de la mitad del sur mucha
precaución con este calor tan intenso en
mayo
la agencia no cataloga como ola de calor
esas temperaturas inusuales para mayo
por no superar las máximas de julio y
agosto anunció que para el próximo lunes
y martes el calor irá descendiendo
finalizando con el fenómeno sin embargo
pronostican que posiblemente los
próximos tres meses con la entrada del
verano serán más calurosos que en años
anteriores
y no todo es diplomacia hay acuerdos en
la visita de joe biden a corea del sur
enmarcada en su primer viaje por asia
como presidente de eeuu
manifestantes salieron a las calles de
seúl para expresar su rechazo a la
visita del mandatario quien junto a su
homólogo y un shock
anunció que ampliarán los ejercicios
militares ante lo que consideran una
amenaza de corea del norte por sus
pruebas de armas nucleares precisamente
los manifestantes expresaron su
preocupación ante el fortalecimiento de
la alianza militar entre seúl y
washington y la posible amenaza a la
seguridad de la península
estoy aquí porque creo que los
ciudadanos de todos los países deberían
trabajar por la paz y no por la división
en este momento creo que algunas de las
políticas que el gobierno de estados
unidos y el gobierno de corea están
siguiendo juntos crearán una mayor
división particularmente en el contexto
del gran conflicto de poder entre china
y los eeuu
sainz a 6 noticias deportivas el
futbolista francés kilian mbappe
continuará formando parte del parís
saint germain hasta el año 2025 el
propio jugador de 23 años había
anunciado en un comunicado su deseo de
quedarse en el club y todo se confirmó
cuando previo al último partido de la
liga mbappe salió portando una camiseta
con el número 2025 fecha en la que
cumplirá su contrato con el club el
anuncio pone fin a una serie de rumores
que vinculaban al jugador con el real
madrid de la liga de fútbol española
y mientras tanto en la frontera sur de
eeuu continúan las expulsiones de
solicitantes de asilo bajo la norma
título 42 que continuará vigente por
orden de un juez federal esta medida fue
la responsable de más de un millón de
retornos el año pasado el informe es de
jorge hurtado
abandonan su pasado en busca de un
futuro a través de una brecha en el muro
que separa méxico y eeuu estos migrantes
centroamericanos se entregan
voluntariamente para pedir asilo les
ofrecen agua
un pequeño gesto para culminar la
peligrosa travesía aunque nada comparado
de lo que vengo también porque a mí me
mató la familia que a mí me han
amenazado para matarme también hay una
blandura y por ahora me viene la carrera
para acá y me vine a ti sin conocer y me
vine alfiler éste de rey teme bien
nosotros creemos pruebas pues y nosotros
venimos preparados preparados no porque
nosotros no queremos porque en nuestro
país tenemos muchas delincuencia tenemos
un presidente que sólo salió del
gobierno y al o mandar un preso aquí en
eeuu por orlando hernández se habla de
llama
pues un asilo protección en las
trampillas un pues federal de luisiana
bloqueó los planes de yo va a ir en
determinar con el título 42 la
controversial medida que impuso donald
trump y que permite la expulsión de
emigrantes argumentando motivos de salud
pública
por el título 42 cerró la frontera y
dijo a los estadounidenses
estamos cerrando la frontera para
protegernos de la pandemia estamos
intentando minimizar la propagación del
cob y 19 cerrando la frontera sin
embargo la frontera siempre estuvo
cerrada para los solicitantes de asilo y
siempre estuvo abierta para el comercio
open for commerce
bajo el título 42 se expulsaron en los
últimos seis meses a casi medio millón
de migrantes tan solo en marzo pasado se
registraron 109 mil expulsiones
33% que el mes anterior
organizaciones humanitarias afirman que
la medida expone a los migrantes a
nuevos peligros al dejarlo sin la
protección que buscan cruzar el muro
cada vez está más lejos de ser el final
de su travesía
y finalizamos en chile donde un grupo de
artesanas mapuches rompió un récord
mundial al elaborar el telar más grande
del mundo quinientas mujeres unieron sus
fuerzas y fabricaron un tejido de un
kilómetro de largo y 50 centímetros de
ancho con los colores del real muy que
significa arco iris en el idioma mapuche
mapudungún para la hazaña se utilizó una
tonelada de lana de oveja que se tiñó
con materiales naturales para conseguir
el arco iris que representa a distintos
valores para la cultura mapuche el
morado por ejemplo simboliza el respeto
por las personas y el verde el respaldo
hacia los otros
con estas imágenes nos despedimos sigan
en france24
[Música]